I'm going to do a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little
bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit
of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of
a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a
little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little
bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit
of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of
a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a
little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little
bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit
of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of
a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a
little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little
bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit
of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit
of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of aotto
I
Hello
What bro I can hear here my girls
Okay, there we go. Bye. Bye. Oh my god. Oh
Hear me
Hi
I'm very anxious
Wow
Oh my gosh, I'm imposter
It's not like this game works
Oh my god, I just thought you guys would like to know
Oh great cool
Let's get ready each girl at her spotlight should come up here. Okay. You may plus first
No, no, no, you may plus you may plus go
I said no
Socky and I like strawberries nice to meet you. Well, why do you have a cherry on your head?
Hello, I'm rea nevermore and I am the goat girl of you may plus first generation remedy
Hello
Sorry, I had you guys off on my desktop. Sorry. Hold on. I'm so dumb
Who's echoing
Ezra
Skits
Can you still hear it or is it gone?
That's good
Me
Oh, I'm stupid. Oh my god, I had it turd down. Oh my god
Welcome to the violour and you met plus
Where we are scoffed even through the beginning even though we met an hour before
It was more than an hour. It's giving poopy
Speaking of poopy let me go
All right, poofy take it away
Why do I feel like I'm an alcohol's anonymous
Uh, I'm rain and I'm the problem
Okay
No, but like seriously, who are you now for violour
Tells what hey, I'm scrawny. I'm Scottish. You can't even mix my voice up with anyone in this lobby and I will not tolerate
Otherwise, thank you
Oh
Yo, what's up? I'm she be cotton bum, but you can call me anytime
Wait, are we starting? Oh god, okay. We are hi. Hi
Wait, why am I in here?
Okay
Oh my god, they're still yelling at her chat
Let's let's do this boom. Bam. I'm not good at omogus
I like haven't played this game
Oh
Already
I literally just saw her I came from the fricking I just came from communication and Amy is
Standing over the body of rain. Holy crap. Yeah, holy crap. No, don't even fucking lie. I'm sorry, but you're into
No, is that the best right? Sorry
That's the best you've got
I want in on it
It's literally a
I'm the only heroes for this fucking shadow role player
Yeah, okay. The already guilty thing I have to admit is that I like shadow, but I didn't
I didn't do this. I promise
Does straw knee set you up
Amy are you joking? I was literally at the gas canister
Watching you as you go to pull the lever and then fucking snipe rain in half her fucking torso is like left behind
I'm sorry, but I'm sorry
I don't know who to vote for
Open up my stream right now. I'm not being
Shadowed the hedgehog streamer
I'm not being gaslit by a freaking sonic the hedgehog
Johnny immediately just be like fuck you now. That's not true
I'm sorry, but you seem you seem suspicious
I would never
If if if it's not I me I'm voting for straw knee next round
Why am I getting in trouble? Obviously, it's gonna be because you're so passionate
You're actually welcome for doing half of the work now. You you all go find the other imposter while you're at it. I'll do it
I'll try my best
I'm gonna die, I think
Straw knee straw knee
mother
Mother
Wait, wait, mercy mercy said she saw it. Mercy reported
I walked in they working together. I don't know about this
I'm gonna I'm gonna go do my shit if somebody kills me it was straw knee
I'm just gonna
Oh
When straw knee talks like that, I know it's fucking her. That's her tail. That's her tail when she's so
Defensive so fast that is straw knees tell
Yes
I can't believe that this happened. I am so hurt
What kind of defenses I didn't do it
And it like oh we got to play prop hunt on gmod at some point
I mean we can't let sonic the head
It was begin right
I'll I'll be a good little girl. I'll do my tests
I keep having to do the same shit
Why it's like the easiest person
I don't I don't like this guys. I don't like this
No, I don't like this bros
Someone's gonna kill me and stab me in the back and I'm just gonna just take it from behind and
Oh fuck
Cool, okay, we're fine. We're good. We're chilling. Um
I'll be fine. Hopefully I'm I'm pretty nervous. I'm not good at a mogul. How do I port?
What the hell
I was doing I was doing
A conversation
I was do let me talk
I found the body let the rabbit speak. Um, so I was doing electrical. It's coming from electrical and I walked up
Down, uh, actually, I don't know where the hell the map works. Hold on. Let me let me look at the map
I walked up near and in between reactor and security
So, okay, and then I found Imi's body
I am I am going to vouch for rea and pink because she was near me all the way
She did I saw her go in the opposite direction. So I think I think rea is fine
Yeah, yeah, he coughed on me
Stroni rea and mercer vouching for one another. She is claiming she saw it. So azura mimosa and rea
Yeah, what do you what do you guys have to say for yourselves?
I have to say something
It was it was not me
How do we know it wasn't you
Because as straw me I was with straw me and then I went to security and I saw what happened
I didn't see who killed well. It was in between security
It was in between security and reactor
Now I did see rain. I did see rain and admin
So azura and mimosa are now the most likely suspects unless she be you're playing mind game
So I'm not I'm not she be are all sus now. Uh, unless ventilation was taken in electrical
I don't believe a word you say azura
I'm innocent because I was I was
I was literally sitting in the at the table. I was sitting at the table because I'm having audio issue
Okay
I don't know who to vote for then I'm gonna vote for mimosa just because I love
Wait, who is the person that said they walk to security?
Who is me I don't know who to vote for
Azura and mimosa have abstained for voting. How fucking curious
I don't recognize people's voices yet
So
Azura is the most fucking likely I'm keeping an eye on Azura
Staring at you
We're getting oh
Hold on a second
It's not me. I promise
Rain don't stab me in the back
It's not me. I promise. She casually walks by
Oh
Why do I feel like it was mercy
She well no mercy mercy just walk past me
Hey, what's up, uh rain walked by me and she said I'm not it. Don't worry. It's not me and we were alone
So she's I think she's good
Yes, it's what what other oh wait, they can't hear me. I walked away. I'm just gonna continue. Oh
Uh
I don't know which way to go. How do I play this game?
Please don't kill me strani
Wait a moment
I's mercy walked by me and disappeared into the nether. I do believe it might be her
I was alone with rain and reya and strani
I think mercy it's mercy
It's not I can't believe you would do such a thing to me
Is there I'm sorry
It would make sense why mercy would vote
I actually like
I probably could have killed I was actually aiming for rain, but I don't know how to
It's mercy walked right past me and I'm surprised you didn't kill me then because I was just like talking to myself like a weirdo
Not accepted
I'm red not blue goddamn
Jesus okay
I'm lying. I forgive you. I I can never be none. All right. They're all lying. Do my tasks and shake my ass. Let's do it
Please don't kill me. I'm I'm working hard
Oh, thank you reya that was nice. I appreciate that
She just jiggled her booty and walked away. Oh, okay. Um
Somebody shut the door
I don't think it was reya
Oh memosa
Okay, are you gonna kill me? No, no like this
Wait
Is in freaking electrical and who does stumble upon puri reya's dead body?
No
She's a victim
Eventually open the door because the door just got closed in my face me and um
The door is also closed on me the opens and then I mean ivy comes out and then
I go in at the back at the vent section and reya's sitting dead with her weak corpse
I mean
Did you tell me to kill myself? No
She just wanted to shake her ass
I was doing electricals
Strani strani when you get like this strani when you get like this
I don't trust you
She's like breaking my microphone
I need to start strani down
She literally goes. I was an electrical. I tell you I find the dead body of reya an electrical
I'm abstaining. I'm abstaining
If it's i me then it might
Well, if it's i me it also might be mimosa because mimosa was cornering me and I saw them walking together
Probably by the table again
Excuse me
Oh my god is i me
It's strani it's strani it's strani hit the button hit the button it's strani
It's
Strani
I'm even kidding to play the game
No, when it goes oh when strani's and I know we impostor
Wait, no mercy mercy always votes for the person that accuses her when she's impostor
It's mercy. It's mercy. It's mercy. If you want to lose this crew me have fun, but I'm here at win and you guys are being
It's
I would love to
Right when I float away in space and it says strani was a weak crew me everyone turned to mercy and vote for her
Thank you very much
By mercy
I should have why didn't I go with my gut? Why didn't I go with my gut? I should have gone with my gut
I knew it. She did the same thing again that she does when she
Oh my god
It's because mercy will accuse someone and vote for somebody who is who is the impostor and accusing her when she's the impostor
And then strani gets so defensive
It's a weeping
I'm so upset
I'm so upset right now
Listen
I'm so mad right now. I'm so I'm so angry. I'm gonna sit in the corner and be upset
All right now
Why am I impostor again
Oh my god
Wait, what's going on?
You guys want to do a little buddy system? Hold on. Let's do a buddy. So who wants to be my buddy?
I don't believe in buddies
Okay, okay guys we got this we got this guys we got this
We're good
I think we're safe
I
Need to find somebody to chill with
What the hell are you guys doing over here?
Okay, all right, there's two there's too many witnesses
Hi me and hey, uh
This is this is suspicious. I don't like these two hanging out
You hear the game
Mercy mercy, I knew this one
Mercy
Are we alone?
Okay, okay, come here come come on the hallway
Wait, okay
Come over here mercy come over here
What are we what are we doing? We need to do a double
What's going on in here
Guys, I think mimosa is too timing all of us. I said she's impostor, but she's not what she is
I don't know but I'm really easily gaslit. So I'm I'm gonna believe
I think okay, I don't want to be with an impostor
I got it. You got it. We can do a double
Yes
I'm I'm thinking come here. Come here. Come here. Come here. I'm thinking
Amy and
Yeah
Hi
You're gonna kill me
I'm not the impostor
Oh, hey
Why
Where the heck is Azura where's Azura at
Where is Azura?
I haven't seen Azura
I'm like so confused. Oh, there you are. I was like, where's Azura?
He died only rain I found rain dead in the back of electrical nobody was nearby
Um, but I have a feeling it might be rea and azura because they like to sit with each other
I saw
In rea together. No, I saw I mean
So rea and I went together for a while and then I was to do tasks and then I was with azura and then she became
I walked in on us. Yeah, I was
I couldn't have vented from electrical to security
And mercy are very unlikely of had to do the tame in order to do electrical unless mercy vented from below
But I actually wait, did I see I don't think that would make any sense. I think it's Azura. I'm sorry
Where were you
I couldn't find Azura the entire time
It's cuz you know what your tell is it's cuz you know what your tell is now, huh, scrawny, so you're you're gonna keep quiet
Yeah, they're for half the fucking round. Are you joking? I've already done
Wait, why did I I was wherever'd he go?
Oh
What's going on
I can't where is everybody I can't find anyone
Hello
I couldn't even see anybody
Oh
I mean, you know
Take five seconds to type in
You underestimate how stupid I am
Okay, well, I guess we'll see I guess we'll see
Mimosa if it's if it's not her then it's you
I don't I don't yeah
Why are you defending the person that's trying to kill you
Yeah, they're lulling you into a full state. Maybe you guys are both the the fucking imposters. I don't trust either one of you now
Rhea and mercy of all the people I trust here
I'm skipping
In space goodbye
Come on
Oh
Defied in
Everybody's just I mean we gotta we gotta give each other
I know you guys
She's our baby. I love you. Okay, that's it. Yeah, Ray's been perfect the entire time. I bet she's gonna be imposter next round, but that's fine
Oh my god, I'm laughing so hard
Yo
I'm tired of sweating mommy memos is coming for you
She better be coming for me
Hi me too pa. You're my buddy now. All right, what am I doing?
I like when people just like disappear in their voices just get cut off
Wait
What
Okay, okay, let her say her piece what I like I found the freaking but I mean you were right next. I just saw you
No, no, no, no, no, I think
Dude, she be was right, man. Dude. No, I think it's right
I think it's right
I walked away. I can't even say anything
I'm skipping my vote. I'm I can't I'm upstanding. I'm upstanding
I literally walked away not knowing where I was going
Listen, if the imposter wins, you guys are gonna lose. Okay. All right, that's all I have to say
All right, I'm starting to think it's rain
No, mercy mercy didn't know where she was going just like me. I heard her walk away and I was laughing about it
Yeah, all right. I mean, I'm gonna give you a free hit. Just kill me
But I'm not the imposter. Are you sure? Yes. All right
You promise
Okay, I believe you
I'll vouch for you
Okay, I don't think it's strawney because she could have just maybe killed me
Um, she would have looped back around. I don't think it's amy
I mean, uh, it might be I think it is rain
I suck at this
Please please please
What oh well, I'm better fixio too
I'm still I'm still doing this thing. Oh, okay. Uh, I think mercy is fine
It's definitely I feel like it's rain
Yeah, I'm trying to run to it
I'm guarding you. I mean I'm guarding you. I'm guarding you. Don't do it mercy
Oh, okay. I did it. I do proud of you. Good job. Good job. Good job. Good job. Really pop. You did it. You did it
Um, I don't know if I trust mercy. I don't know if I trust mercy. I don't know if I trust mercy
I definitely don't trust rain
Imi's good straw. He's good
It's not Imi
It's definitely rain. I'm voting for rain
Azura is gonna fucking I keep forgetting Azura is around
Azura kind of probably killed me right then. I might not be Azura, but it's definitely rain
How many do I have to do?
Okay, cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Uh, I think I'm gonna go stick to Imi
Where is Imi?
What on earth
Listen, I still think it's freaking I know it's not rain. It's you. It's you rain
It's rain
So mercy, I don't know where straw knee was straw knee. Uh, I saw her like a long time ago
But mercy was in the hallway next to admin
I had walked all the way from weapons through cafeteria and then found her body there
Where rea rea, where did you come from?
I went from so I went in the circle. I went from admin to down and then through I think it's
So, hold on. So you were the last one to see mercy?
Yeah, I was I think actually
Cackles you I'm voting rain because she's a sure yes
I'm voting rain
Listen, I'm pretty sure it's rea or she be then okay
I was shooting asteroids Azura. You saw me sit in there. You walked by she be sitting there
But it's either she be or rea because rea was the last to see
No, no, no, no, no, but but I was with you as solo in security. Yeah
Oh, I wasn't really dude. I was with you and Azura in security to rea, but listen. I thought it was imi
I think it might be
I don't think it's I I don't know anyone that I know it's imi is one of them
Yes, I
I we had every chance to kill me. We were alone so many times
Really?
And I didn't do it. We stood and talked. We had a lovely conversation
I watched her do the oxygen
I think she's grooming you I think it's Azura and rain
I did I did see you walk past me, but you could have looped back around you might have been waiting for your moment
That's impossible because I literally ran past
Uh rain and
I don't think it's
Okay, listen, I know it. I don't think it's Azura at all. I think it's imi and rea
Oh, shit. It doesn't matter rain get out of here
All right, all right, so uh, okay, then who's it gonna be who's gonna be amy amy amy amy amy
Uh, if they kill one of us that means we lose so we need to stick together
Uh, or we can hit the table oxygen depleted. It's Azura. It's Azura. It's Azura. It's Azura. It's Azura
It's Azura. I don't trust this. No, no, I can't
Oh, no, oh, no, I mean, no
If imy kills me, I'm gonna cry
I trust in you
It was rain so hard voting for her own
Dude, I was trying to help her so you guys wouldn't think it was her
Yeah
Honestly, yeah masterclass rain strat masterclass rain strat
Anyway, I'm so upset
It was it was a good strat it was a good strat
Do you want to take a little breaky poo we all can chat
So good
I have never felt so betrayed in my entire life
Get away from me. I mean don't look at me anymore. I trusted you
I'm so sorry. I mean when much she needed a little help
I
She stabbed me in the back when I was doing oh, too
I mean loves being bullied and teased guys she loves it. You see, you know
The long
What happened
Is someone echoing
Someone's game is echoing
That was pretty that was a good round I got a I got a hand to you guys for the strat I got a hand to you guys
It's pretty good. I'm upset, but it's whatever
Rae, I'm right next to you. So I think we're we're both doing the cow card. So we should be good
So did I it's fine
I I had a feeling they were gonna pull a double on us. I had a feeling the moment they walked in
I know yeah, we were both right on top of each other for that
I guess I could do tasks while I'm dead
I
Hi, hi, what's up?
She was standing right there, I walk into the card room. Oh no mercy and then mercy then reports
She was in shock
Oh my god, how would she possibly kill people I want nervous she saw me
This would be the fastest round ever
It's a self-report. Oh my gosh
I saw the bodies and started screaming
No
When that oxygen thing comes on, what do you did I look at the wrong part of the map for the oxygen because I was trying to turn it back on
Look at fucking do you hear Strani lying right now? Do you hear her pulling shit out of her ass?
I I cannot trust
Strani ever again
I can never I don't know why any of you ever trust Strani. I've never trusted Strani
I was trying to do the oxygen and it wasn't working and I didn't know what I was doing
To say that I'm top left
I will choose who the imposter is
Okay, go for it
I was like
Me and reya we're just swiping our cards having a jolly good time and then these two come in
Literally and they've doubled us
Body
She was in so much shock
Oh god
I don't trust a word strani says
Never trust strani. What am I doing? Never trust strani. Uh, mercy. You're scaring me
Mercy, you're scaring me mercy. Mercy. You're scaring me mercy
She's quiet
She's laughing evilly and she's chasing me with a knife in her hands. I can't even
Where's the reactor it's having a meltdown. I don't know what to do. Mamosa. Please don't kill me
Please don't be having double
Wait, how the fuck do I do this one?
Oh, I just pressed it twice
Please nobody stab me in the back. I'm very focused
Meow meow meow
See I did the task I am cool. I'm good. You guys all saw that
Okay, I'm gonna go
Me and is there a on a mission we're gonna go fix this oxygen unless she stabs me in the back
Oh
My god, oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Strani wait, what?
Oh, okay
I'm innocent
What am I supposed to do next? I want to fix
Whoa
Ivy can never play. Ivy's just not allowed to play
She's not allowed to play
I'll I'll be on
Yeah, you guys saw me doing the reactor shit. I don't know how the simon says thing works
I was a navigation
I was in wiring in front of azure mercy is sus though. She was laughing easily
Chasing me down a hallway. I ran into the open arms of mimosa
That's really fun. Let's see rain. Who were you with?
I was with the mercy tasks
rain and mercy
I don't where was reya. Where was reya at camp?
Oh, okay, I was also at the zero at one point
I don't remember this speak your truth. I didn't what? I didn't accuse anyone. I have no clue what's going on
I have no mercy for Ivy
It took a hot second to do any type of task. She followed me from cafeteria
I was strutting when you talk, I don't believe you
I
Can't handle the lies anymore
To
Mercy wait
I don't I don't I don't I think it's mercy. I don't
Is is that your cat? Yes
Is mimosa self-report is my only inclination and then god don't tell them
Okay, I don't know who to vote for guys. I don't know
I abstain rain abstained look at you. Well shifty eyes. Don't touch me
I don't know I don't know I don't know who to believe
Leave me
No, I don't I want to stay away from mercy azura stay with me
Wait, actually, no your eyes. No, never mind. Just get away from me
I'm I'm gonna hang out with strongy. I'm checking
All right
You can see cameras when I look at camera. Yeah, yeah, we can both look at cameras. All right. I strongy mom. I think we're both good
Okay, I'm happy to say we're good if you're good. Okay
That'd be hilarious if you killed me azura is literally lingering outside because she's waiting for one of us to be alone
She can kill us
I actually have to do a task for him, right? Okay. I'm gonna go bait her and if I die
No, don't no don't wait come with me ball. Okay. Okay. Okay. I
Oh, it doesn't matter
What oh azura it's azura
Dude, I think it's azura too. I saw her walking into electrical. I think it's azura and mercy
And I found a body. What the fuck?
What the fuck me and strongy are good. I was hanging out strongy looking at cameras
Azura was lurking around in camera
But then also mercy's someone to follow being creepy. Uh, I'm gonna vote for mercy because she don't trust how she's looking at me
Oh when you killed her
It's rain
But why where's the reasoning azura
I said it. I was literally with you guys in I was literally with you guys in security
I went to security with you guys and then I went up
I went and did my task and came back down and she said did she accuse me
Did she accuse me
All right, all right strongy stay with me strongy strongy strongy strongy come back
All right, trust any of you guys man. I'm sticking with you strongy. Uh, do I have anything to do it down here?
It's mercy and rain
They were gonna double kill they win if they do a double kill they win
Azura you have to listen to us
Okay, we're voting rain. We're voting rain. We're voting rain. We're voting rain
Because her and mercy almost doubled me and strongy. That's all i'm gonna say
Man, you guys were you guys were lining yourselves up to stab me in my butthole. I don't I don't believe you
It's mercy it's mercy it's mercy hit the button hit the button. I can't call it
He's
It's mercy
She's creeping me out
She's running in a circle chasing me and strongy when I actually have the chance to actually like pay attention
What is her
Because I spent the entire game fucking with other shit and now I get to finally play. Yeah
If Azura is an impostor, I'm really gonna commit
Yeah, they were gonna double us they were gonna double us
Nice the gamer instincts
We did that round
Oh, I said go brothers
Can we start can we start an esports team?
Oh, come on
I think it's just hydrate remember hydrate because it's gonna work roughly
Thank you. I mean, I'm sorry. I've been I've been bullying you a little too much this round. All right. All right. Let's see. Who can I trust?
A little bit. Yeah, where am I supposed to go?
Okay, I remember this. I mean, I hope I hope you
Have you been thinking about what you've done
To me. Yeah, how you betray how does?
I I cared for you deeply
I'm actually a really big fan of you and I feel really
What?
Yeah
I'm a big fan
All right, I'll
I'll give you
Watch her kill me again. I swear to god my most look at the fuck away from me
My most look at the fuck away from me
Let's do the card swipe together
Oh my gosh, I got it in one go
It's a stack
That's impossible
Merchie's lying
I want to make a note
Hit the button hit the button if you think it's her I swear right I come here. I need my buddy
I need my buddy. Let's go together. Are you always say that when you're not you always say that?
What am I supposed to do? Oh, I should go to the med bay
Me
What's happening in here?
No, don't kill me
I gotta con show you
Me
I'm keeping my eye on her
Okay, we need to do oxygen though if she dies that it's definitely Mamosa
Okay, uh, we're all gonna fucking die
Guys oh, I'm not gonna make it
Uh
I did watch I but I don't know you broke my trust before I mean, I don't know. I don't know what to say
I I I don't know who to I don't know who you trust
Oh
I mean I mean I mean
I don't I don't believe any of this. I don't believe any of this. I don't I don't I don't trust any of this
Fuck
I
Don't
Cause she was so adamant
It's the same tears as before
I'm gonna do what I must I'm doing what I must I'm doing what I must I don't trust you
Wait, Shrani's been very quiet
No
Okay, okay
I fucking knew it. Okay, we only gotta do the reactor now
Where'd reya go reya hasn't been in posture. It has to be her turn now
I think it may be real and I wrote it clear
Shrani are you gonna kill me?
I need I need your help cool
Uh, all right, I think we're good
Let's see I'm gonna go I'm going to admin
Gotta do to actually I gotta
Oh
Sad
Yeah, my whole bone my whole bonus is taken out
Oh
Mercy mercy find me
I mean I had a feeling it was reya the moment she abstained
Strony baloney because
Yeah, yeah, it's Strony. Why because
Oh
Look at look at look at reya. Oh, that it's mercy
Please I think reya's gonna win this
I think I think reya's gonna clutch this
Why does this are keep calling her strony
So cute to be in posture
Oh my god the clutch the clutch I can't believe it I can't believe it
I
Can't believe it
It's always the cute ones. It's always
Reya vented and killed me at bed bay
I was like, oh shit. Look strony. Strony. You said it was mercy. You said it was mercy
But you instantly went for me
It's because you said it was mercy
Yeah, that was pretty good that was a good that was that was clutch
Wait, wait, I should uh go up here. I need a drink of water
I hate that I can't see anything
I'm waiting for someone to walk around me
All right, all right, we're good. We're golden. We're good. We're living like Larry. I don't see anybody
I'm a I'm a little nervous
I
Mercy are you gonna get me?
What are you doing? I'm just doing my tasks mercy
Oh
They were so fast
What even happened
Strony was all like three two one trouble and then they got me in azura
I'm such a painter. I'm a painter for Strony. Holy shit
Oh my god, can we get an imposter, please?
We're missing someone. Wait, you guys start lobby too fast. You got to wait for people to join the lobby for
Oh
Okay, okay, how do we can we exit the game how?
We have to make this lobby then
Oh my god, brah, all ready
Vote them off vote them off
Who was it rea and
It was rea and azura. Okay. Sorry. I thought we were all here. I'm not the imposter
It was rea and azura
Yeah, but off the imposters. We're missing people. We gotta restart the lobby
Let's vote the let's vote the baby off first. Okay, the baby first
Hi rea. I'm smiling. Bye. Bye
That was my bad guys. I thought we were all here
Okay, who's next?
Hi
Is mimosa dead? Like what word word do mimosa go?
Bring her on the rose. Oh, okay. I thought she's just she's just quiet. Yeah
It was the other imposter. What are you hungry for?
You
Me
Oh, yeah, I'm your sister though
Even better
What?
Oh, no
All right, who is it mim's rain. I cannot believe you just did that
Okay, because we got to get mercy back in. Okay, mim's just I don't even know man. Okay
Now it's mimosa
Is that how you pronounce it shabby shabby shabby shabby shibbers shibberton shibbillit shibbethany
I did it for us
All right, I'm gonna go get some water
I got it
Yeah
Thanks a lot. I like
I like how I know I make canik runs. She does like this in the lobby. I like how she does that
Game could make me and Mary play the imposter again for another flawless victory. That'd be great
You guys are really good imposter. I haven't gotten imposter once
I fucking love it
And when there's two of us together, I love going three two one
Anyways, my next goal is to follow someone just for fun. No
Why do you sound so far away?
Oh
I like how her kitchen is right next to her gus. That's cool. I want food right next to me all the time
I like believed her I believed her
She doesn't even like change the tone of her voice
You can't you didn't change your tone of voice at all when lying
Is that 200 by people never trust reya? I can't tell
You can tell really good mercy you caught on to me
My mouth is dry
I'm sorry Reya
Thank you, she knew
I am
I believe
I believe right until the end
I can never tell if she is ever lying or not. I can never tell if
I can tell
And loud
Because every time you you you don't let someone finish
It feels like you're being defensive and not letting the person speak. So you
I assume that you're the yeah
You gotta let me you gotta give me really gotta let me explain the reason
You
You gotta you gotta let me explain why and then you have to tell me why I'm wrong
Well, yeah, because you didn't let me speak
Yeah
Oh
40 days
Biblical suspension
Yeah
So I'll say one thing the girls have never seen me
Any other type of motion other than like happy and proud of their work
So playing among us when I'm screaming down the make being like it's fucking
Is probably quite a surprise. It is I was just like
Nice and refreshing
I want to I want to see a zara and rea or stronti and rea team up. That's what I want to say. That'd be funny
I haven't gotten imposter once
Yeah, guys, let's give us a chance
Let's give us our imposter the statistics of a zero being imposter very high. No, just keep that in mind
By the way for your probability
Don't do that. See look. She's gaslighting you man. I'm gonna get killed. She says things like this
Everybody
I'm eating goldfish
This is a regular kind of goldfish always sus stronti because he says the sus is shit ever
Again
Over here
My cat is walking around my desk, sir
What are you looking for? There's nothing here for you. Sorry. I'm talking to my cat. Hi stronti
What do you want dude
You can hang out
Okay
Hmm
Lotta D lotta da
lotta do
Just doing the work. I'm supposed to
Because that's what bunnies do
I'm pretty good at my job
I could eat some corn on the cob
Don't know
Wait, where's the body? Where was the other body? Oh my god. Oh my god. Holy shit. All right. Well
Wait, where was everyone? I was about to report wait, wait, wait, where's my let me talk to she saw the body
Rae was literally with me and stronti as well. I saw stronti. I passed by those two
I wasn't like your cold. There was a body there
Um, well
First of all
Excuse me
Secondly, I was shooting asteroids and I walked down and there was a body at oxygen and it was mimosa
She was probably doing like a little shoot being up by is anyone being a navigation or two or weapons?
Yes, or no. Yes. No, I was in cafeteria
I was about to do electrical. Who is cafeteria? I know it's stronti. I just know it's stronti. I just know it's stronti
No, I think you're fucking wait. Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute. I see who's been near
weapons o2 navigation because you have reported the body and where o2 and you automatically go is stronti
Sorry, I know you love playing these main games
No, no, no, no, I was shooting asteroids. It's stronti. I mean, it's stronti
Notice how I'm nice and calm and she's freaking out and that's almost that
Because you're picking on me when you were self reported the body when you're the only person who's been witness
Or two navigation well clearly because the body was wait was there for a lot longer
The body must have been there for a while
I was chilling in the cafeteria talking to my cat and then I went and shot some asteroids
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I mean, who are you with again? I was with reya and stronti was in the room with us when we swiped the cards
Yeah, I was in the acting room. We were hanging out
Where was reya's body?
No, I didn't know because she was alive and then when she walked off and then
That's and then I was singing a song going somewhere
When the round goes fast is stronti because stronti kills fast
All right, thank you, thank you. Thank you. Oh my god
Good luck
Oh
The moment she starts getting defensive and loud she is the imposter
I know that's what I mean. I'm like I had had to have happened long ago
I wish you guys could see all the gesturing that I'm doing right now
I do I was chilling eating golden fish you are evil
When the when the killing goes fast and when she gets defensive, you know, it's stronti
When reya up same
It's reya
When rain starts accusing her own teammates, it's rain
I'm learning I'm learning their strats
I
Don't accuse my teammates all the time
That's just her strats to kill her teammates
Oh, no, don't die you're so hot
Hi
All right, um
Mamosa
Mercy, why are you guys following me? I don't I'm choking a goldfish. I don't trust I don't trust either of you
It's not me. I'm watching rain. I'm watching. No
I'm gonna get a little closer. No, get away from me. Get away from me. Get away from me. Please. Please. No. No, it's not me
It's not me. It's not me. It's not me. Oh, please you guys are so
So accusatory
What do you mean? I'm so accusatory. You're the one who is following azura
Because I was apologizing to her
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah likely story rain likely story
I heard going us to look look, you know, I'll cover for you, but then they found the body and like I have to kill
You know, I'm sorry. Okay, that's what happened last time. All right
All right, you're gonna kill me the orange you what I'm literally doing my own thing. I'm trying to get over here
I don't know
Hello
Are you sniffing me?
Hey, I want everyone to tell me their location right now. I was sniffing shabby
She was I was doing the events or whatever it's called
Okay, it's not azura. I promise you
I think it's rain
I saw rain
Stocking azura
That's all I'm gonna say
Are you kidding me? I said no, no, I'm not saying it's you. I'm saying it's rain. Oh
No, let me vouch for people. It's not azura or shibi. Okay. Look, let's see. I'm vouching for people
It's definitely because shibi was following me and then I was following azura and then Amy. Imi was sniffing my ass
Who I was doing the leaves
Listen, I don't want to ditch my gen
Look, I don't want to accuse my gen but Imi like you're a little bit quieter than she usually are
Strawny, why are you so quiet?
I'm in storage with
We're on our way to cafeteria azura and I
I was in storage with Imi
That is me and shibi
Imi
So then mercy and Imi then
I will only say that I was not with rain the entire time
I don't know if it's rain or Imi if Imi was biting her time because she almost hurt me again
I think it's mercy
I'm voting rain. I'm voting rain. Whatever. I don't know. I don't fucking know. Imi. I swear to god. Imi
Yeah, mercy, what the hell
It's mercy and Imi
I don't know man. I don't know man. I don't know man. I don't know man. I don't know man
Are we just moving in a pack now?
Fuck
What are you talking about rain?
Actually
Don't trust you
Trust I swear to god
You
Oh my god
What what is going on?
But I knew it was mercy too I had a
You
Didn't get a chance to say because mercy was I saw mercy mercy was the last person I got a kill
I like to abide my time I knew it was mercy because mercy was the last one with rea and I was trying to tell you guys
I know I know you're sipping the ass of a killer
Is
Because I was hoping that mercy would read my mind and we would do a double but it didn't happen
Well, I don't trust the what are you a princess?
I'm a rain cloud man
You know what rain, where are you? I'm gonna keep my eye on you
What the fuck is going on in here?
I'm so anxious right now. I cannot
And I need
Oh what the hell
I
Killed the most on the way to oxygen she's like are you baiting me?
Yes, the sabotage you supposed to fix it
That was good. We didn't even have to do anything. I just took out mimosa on the way to who was gonna go ghetto
Yeah, I killed mimosa before she could start us camping. We don't have our eighth. We don't have our eighth. It's me. Hello
Oh my god, all right, that scared me. It's all right. Okay
I love it here
I
Imagine a third time
Dude, I've been imposter like what five times already is crazy rain. You're not
You're not doing yourself any favors. I didn't I didn't say this round. Come on
Listen, I know I blame I me all the time, but I think it's her this time
She's literally just doing the task with mimosa, you know what I'm gonna follow her
Uh, you were about to vent weren't you you were about to vent I swear to god
I'll watch you do scan rya
Who else wants to watch the scan?
Hello
Only three people
I don't wanna be
You were run so fast mercy come with us mercy come over here
No, wait, this is a bad idea if there's double get out of here. Okay, there's five of us. It's fine. It's five of us
There's five of us. It's fine
Okay, I'm scanning. All right, rya's good
Oh
Wait, hold on
No
No, no, no, no, rya's fine. Rya's fine. I watched your scan. I watched mercy
Strony
Why are you admitting it?
Where did you find rya?
Rya was in med bay at med bay. I watched her do a scan with stronty
And then mercy
It's not azura. I'm just vouching for azura. I saw azura walk in that direction towards uh,
Whatever, it's called the navigation. I think she's fine
Uh, azura is fine. I think
It's mercy
If it's not i'm gonna be really upset because I
Why did you report her body you walked right past it mercy? I did
She's mercy. You're terrible. You're terrible at this
Listen, it's mimosa and mercy. I trust you think I don't know. I think it's you and I think it's iran
It's not guys. I was the one who reported it. I wasn't yeah. No, mimosa's fine. Mimosa's fine
I did it. I killed stronty
I ran to mimosa in fear
You vote for yourself
I
Wasn't paying attention to anything so I didn't vote she needs to pee have a have a good idle eating girly pop
That's why she's like kill me. All right. All right. All right
Okay, we don't have to worry about a double
All right
Azura are you sure? I mean you were okay one side
All right, what's this thing? I'm scanning. I don't know how to
It's downloading something
Hmm
It's doing like tubing with putting liquid into it. Okay. All right. I mean
If I was lying my fish wouldn't change and she'd be watching me skin
Yeah, no. Yeah. Ray is fine. Ray is cool. Uh, I just saw uh, Imi and medbay. Um, she said she was
I'm gonna follow Imi because she's a little, you know, so I'll follow if I die, you know, it's Imi then. Okay. Okay
Hmm. Yeah, I'm sorry. I haven't sabotaged
I was downloading data. I have to wait. I have to go back to medbay later, too
She's focused she's locked in
It's not me. I promise. I'm just sussing you out a little bit. I don't know about that. I don't know about that
It's listen. It's one of the jotes. It's mercy rosara. I bet one of the jotes
I need to what am I doing? Where's my I have to fix?
Wait, is it is it is it rain? No, it's not. Oh my god. It's rain. All right the go
She be it's not it's freaking. I'm sacrificing myself. Do it. Do it. Do it. It's not me
It's Imi she's gonna do it
Do it. What have you do it the other person report?
Fine. Go do it rain. Go on. No, you go on. You do it. It's you. Go on then
Go on then. I'm gonna check on his
Show up. Go on then. Show us your bitch
Wait, where the fuck did rain just go?
I'm not your bitch. It's a stupid task here
No, it's a
Where's Azura?
I was vouching for wait a second. I heard you whispering to yourself Azura
Yeah
No
What were you whispering you sounded hella sus. It's like you you said, where did she go? Where did she go?
I'm listening
I have a feeling I could be wrong. I you you trust me on this one. I promise. I'm not lying
It's I'm just I thought it was Imi, but I think it might be rea or Azura. Okay. It's not rea
It's literally not rea. I watched her do a body scan
Just didn't kill anyone that first round. It's Azura or Imi trust them. Okay. Where's Imi?
Where is she? She dead somewhere? Okay, she's right here
Okay, I need to do some my tasks. How about that? All right, me too. All right, Imi if it's
Oh mimosa mimosa
It might be mimosa because she did a double take but then she realized somebody was nearby
I need to tell somebody this information
Okay, I'm gonna tell you something in case I die. No
It might be mimosa because she did a double take but then she saw rea was nearby
Oh my god. Oh wait. Just kidding. Nevermind. It's Imi
Oh my god
Oh, okay. Well, it's not mimosa
No, no, uh rain was with me a rain was with me
I I went yeah, I was with everyone and I ran over to rain to tell her that I thought it was mimosa, but apparently it's not because she's dead
Because mimosa did a double take and I thought she was gonna kill me
I didn't see her. I didn't see her killer though. Listen, if it's not Imi. It's rea. Trust me. No, it's not rea
I saw her do a body scan, but she's the one like she might not have killed that round. I'm sorry. Imi
Oh, no
Oh
Wait a second. It's not me rain. You just have a seductive suspicious suspicious voice
Listen, I solemnly swear. Okay, rea. We're the only ones we can trust
We have to figure out if it's a zur or rain
I think it's rea
It's not rea. I saw her do a body scan. All right, then it's a zur. I don't know. Let's let's vote
It's not
No, no, no, but that was just the first time you you might have not killed. I don't yeah
And in all the other times like how could I have killed okay rea? We need we guys in the in the shoot room
We have to be good on this
We need to think of back our steps. Okay
Who was what if it's she be because rea said that she be never scanned?
Well, I didn't have a scan. I that was my thing. She be could be yeah
How how we how are we gonna know that she be could be claiming hold on she be could be marinating rea
Rea, I've been nothing but defend you at mimo's death each one of you I was with rain you're at admin
Guys she be had like five opportunities to kill me and she never did and then she unless she's trying to gaslight
I mean, oh my god. Yes, because it because it might be a zero gaslighting you because if mercy
Like if mercy was the imposter and it's only one
Imposter you think me and mercy you're gonna be imposter together three times in a row
Yeah, Roni was literally imposter like four times in a row. I would believe it rea you have to like we have
Rea you have to believe me. I'm sorry. No, it's not me rea. Who do you want to vote for?
I will vote for whoever you want to vote for
I think it's rain
All right. Love just built me off and win. Is that what she want? I'm not the imposter. I don't know
I'm sorry, is there if it wasn't you I apologize
Yes, yes, yes, we did it. I told you
I vouched for you
I had your back. Don't forget that
I can I can I'm a sleuth like it becomes more apparent who the
I was getting nervous because I didn't know how to defend myself running around the map, which is crazy
I'm just teasing. I'm sorry
I'm not sorry because you mercy back from pissing
I
Pissing all by yourself
Well, maybe you're a poster again right now
Mercy left the game
The mercy why did mercy leave?
Okay, I'll hang out with you should I should I just call a meeting
Mercy left so we were just concerned
She didn't die we don't know
Oh, she just got disconnected. Yeah. Yeah, let's throw it out
Rain it's it's it's not me. It's not guys. Okay. No, but delay is getting her back in
Wait, was it Imi
Got it twice in a row
The way that she said how she denied it how she was like, yeah, imagine
Okay
Yep, yep, yep, get away from me
Everybody stand on the side of the table
All right, I'll press the button. I like pressing buttons. You press that button girl
Okay
Yay, it's not really much of a conclusion other than us all accusing each other and never talking
We deserve a call
Is there what do you have to say for yourself
I'm never gonna get on posture again. Yeah, what the heck is that? I really needed for a second. Yeah, it sounds like popcorn
Is
Mike just
Who's pissing who's frying some chicken
Is it mimosa I hear static and when I turn my like voice chat dial down I still hear it
Yeah, let me tell mercy's back
One at a time. Yeah, I'm gonna mute right now. Hold on
No, you can still hear it. Okay, it's not me then I'm muted
I'm gonna mute. Hang on. Let me see if it's me if you hear it. Oh, it's gone now. It's gone now
I didn't you
Is it gone?
I would like
Hey
It's the last game
Oh, right. Second to last, second to last, second to last, second to last
I'm gonna stick with cv then
Wait. What's that then?
Not much man. Oh, I get it. Your leaves look like your bunny ears. Is that what you're going for?
I'm a carrot
Oh, I thought you were like a weird-looking rabbit. No
No, I mean
Right as she's bullying me
She's saying I'm a weird looking rabbit
She's the ice holder I was a carrot Mamosa. Why are you standing scarily to the side?
Waiting for her moment like hello, where's a zero
Oh
Okay, it's not she be or rea
Well, I wasn't near medbay. I was all around the perimeter rain saw me doing the leaves and I was on cam
Strani
Hold on hold on
Wait, is it a Zura's Mike
Who said scrawny three times in a row do it again. I dare you
I
No, wait, Mamosa Mamosa Mamosa let her here let her let Mamosa talk Mamosa. Where were you?
Don't know who to put I don't know if it's Johnny or Mamosa. I don't know if it's Johnny or Mamosa
You think it's it's Johnny Mamosa. Oh, no, I wish I voted
Yeah
It's Johnny, it's Johnny
Dude
Oh my god
Where's rea if it's the joke oh, she's right here hi
Think it's the Joe, why do you think it's
Why do you think it's why do you think it's I'm so nervous
Focus I just can't hear it. I just can't hear you where she goes. I know I heard it too
I have seen because I knew if I voted I feel like I would have tied it
You did the same thing to me when we both were innocent
He doesn't listen to people
Refling has said it's not about Johnny being nice or not
It's about me being dangerous which has been proven in previous rounds
Leave me when I'm freaking a crewmate
Yeah, it's true and every time every time we start you always say that it's probably always gonna be someone or you say that
I hope scrawny is an imposter
First
She's a pasta don't worry mercy. I'll guard you with rea
That will be so funny if like it is scrawny and she comes
Please don't hurt me. Oh, I'm really focused on this card read. Can you guys go do that?
I
No, it's not I was actually just with scrawny
Talking you're talking to the wall talking to your chat and it was quite cute. So I was just staring at you
So it wasn't you
As soon as it's her as soon as she blames me, I know it's rain. I know it's rain
Her accent
It was the dealio so my most offense the body wear we found out of reactor
I
Was just swiping a card
And I told you guys to go worry about that
Whatever man
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, it's raining too quiet rains me too quiet
The other one is obviously strong
If I die scrawny killed me
Yeah, yeah, yeah, no, I think scrawny's fine
I actually had to do bed Bay. I have to do scan scrawny. Do I watch you didn't scan. I'm doing fucking
Well, oh, yeah, it's not me and scrawny
What's going on guys
I
Already did my card swipe
Yeah, cuz me me and scrawny were hanging on medbay, so I believe Rhea's claim on the fifth card Mamosa
Mamosa say your piece
I don't I don't know who to vote for I was with scrawny and medbay
Yeah, we were we were touching each other up in medbay she was watching she was doing a full body scan am I a delicious bod
Mamosa she could have killed me at any time and it could have been like well now we can't hit the button
Oh, no, I
If it's scrawny, I'm literally gonna cry
Okay, we're good. I feel like I should go hit the button. No
I don't trust it. I don't trust it. I don't trust it. I don't trust it. I don't trust it
Going for the button. I'm going for the button. I'm going. No wait. Maybe it's not I mean I
Feel like I feel like I feel like oh no
Are you serious
No, I was
The button
Okay, okay, okay, scrawny, scrawny, where are you?
Oh, I don't think it's I me she could have killed me
Wait, what happened wait what happened everyone you guys don't clear the sabotage no one ever clears the sabotage
Oh
Not the lights the lights doesn't yeah, I said that we won
I'm
One more one more one more one more we need a good finish
I was trying to include you in the imposter ring
Me to cover you I'm so proud of you. That's a go back in my my vaughn
Oh, no, we didn't even clear the tasks. I just look at the bar
That's so weird, I don't know why
Who was the other imposter it was me. Oh, it was okay
I had a feeling it was
Rhea cuz she she was very quiet
Sometimes I walk places cuz I like again, I don't really I just wait for someone to die. I
Like most of the time forget and I hate doing stuff on electrical
Because it's perfect time for someone to come up and stab you in the back
And I'm nervous. Oh, okay, you guys are here cool. I feel a little better unless you both kill me that would be awkward
Oh
Someone got disconnected and that's why the game ended. That's why
One of the hair was telling me
Together in medbay you both together in medbay and I walked into medbay and she was dead
You killed her in medbay you both were together
We both saw you
Listen to me. All right, so we were talking we were hanging outside of maybe me and ame was looking outside of medbay
We were looking outside of maybe yeah, mercy and
mercy and rain was in medbay together and
Ame went off and then I went down and rain was dead
Okay, you want me to tell my story? I walked into medbay. I did the little thing
It said I was purple three as purple three and I told rain to guard me
Because I didn't trust rain and then I walk outside. I lost rain for a second. I walk out and I see Azra kill rain
I saw the body. Why you've been so good at gaslighting this entire time
Something tells me it's Azra. I've had so many L's. I've had so many L's this entire time
Something tells me it's Azra, but I'm gonna skip
I have seen from this note
See
She was a bit shaky she was
Mercy just know if you're not an imposter. I didn't kill you
Watch this
I had a feeling I told you my gut doesn't lie
All right, all right, all right
Because there is still a bit there's a vent in medbay. There's still a bit. I'm keeping an eye
I'm keeping an eye on Azra
You could stay with me trust stay with me. It's not me
Stay with me. It's funny if I just fucking died
It's not me trust us
You know what I'm gonna go over here cuz I'm too lazy. Hey, what's up? I'm a most I'm a most you've been quiet. What's up, baby girl?
I
Should have voted for it, but even if I vote for a zero would have been a tie
Everybody she's satisfied
We gotta play gargoyle phone with you guys
I will this is this has been a stain
Rain's voice never falters when she's an imposter also cutely evil
Disconnected no, that's what happened
Thank you for doing this collab with us. We really appreciate it girls. Thanks for having us indulge in your remedy
We can remedy and
Oh, right, okay
Right, thank you so so much. I'm going to leave the lobby and I'm gonna say a little goodbye to my chat
Thank you very much
Oh
Wait cuz we're also in game a little
Like down here
Oh
What did you think?
right as a Machiavellian
So much blood. I have never seen strutting it's so
Just the just the passion and determination
Anytime she defended herself was so funny and it was it's it's it's good learning of
The girls tells I'm like I was pretty good with my instincts
I was so good with my instincts, but then I just I didn't trust myself. I didn't trust myself
She said I know she wasn't she just it's just she does. This is her voice
I am I am the detective. I like a hundred percent want to play prop hunt with these girls
I think that would be so fun or TTT
TTT would be so
Hilarious, I have to make sure that everyone gets scary spot. I will literally buy it for all of them
Cuz I just think it would be so funny if we played those games together
Yeah, the chaos of TT. Oh a hundred percent if we had and I think that would be like all-gen thing because I really want it
like Mero and
And I see an Emmy to be there cuz like I think that would be so funny
TT prop hunter jailbreak. Yeah, I also used to play like or like murder
Like the clue house. That would be so funny
Um, I got the Batman attacks of skills you bet. Oh, but yeah, it was a lot of fun
So I haven't it's so fun hanging out with my gen mates
But then like because we're all in call for like an hour before and we're just like shooting the shit
Get to know each other setting things up and it was so fun. Just chatting with them
Then please check out the you may plus girls. Um, I don't
Know if my nice son added their information to the description. So I'm just going to post
their links
Let me find those give me one second
And
You may plus
I mean it's so cute. I can't go for her accent
Okay, let me cuz she's first. Let's go to their Twitter's
I
Me please go follow them. They're so sweet
You know, you can you can do the hunt down all the links, you know what I should have done
I should have pinned it, but it's too late now. I've made my choice
I'm getting bullied early was
Oh, it was so because it's just funny because you just scream and I didn't expect that from her because she's so chill
and um
Screaming in the call this Australian screams and it was hilarious
Mara wasn't in the collab, but I'm also posting her link because everybody deserves a love
Oh
Rhea has the cutest voice
It's the most screech. I know I'm like I I couldn't even like talk a lot because I was like I couldn't get an edge
It like I couldn't get a word's
Edge of word, you know the expression
But that was so fun, I hope you guys enjoyed let me find somebody to
Read into
I
Don't know if like well, I don't know if strong you will continue streaming or is there I should have asked one of them first
Or the other girls before they ended
It'd be funny if I just rated it into strongy
Let me ask any of them
If not, then I'll just read somebody else
But how are you guys doing? I hope you guys had a good day I was gonna do a
Gorilla stream today, but then I ended up doing some errands
My vacuum just came in clean my house tomorrow
And then I also had to record some stuff because I was doing a smart collab with someone
So I don't know when that would come out, but pretty soon
So I hope you guys look forward to that. It's his roommate base. It's a it's a collab though with a girl outside of
Feel her which would be really nice and I'm happy that they decided to collab with me for ASMR video
Very exciting
Nobody answered me
I don't know how to read it's literally
All the girls
I'm gonna add them hold on I
Need more friends just kidding. Well, yes, I could I always want more friends
Cuz literally the only person I could rate is Pippa and I'm I do not have the balls for that right now
I'm just gonna raid strongy
Funny so be like what the hell
Who knows maybe she'll surprise us and she'll just stream for another like 12 hours because she'll never sleep
Okay, well have a lovely night everybody. I hope you guys enjoyed
My little Bible studies that I posted the last few days last few days. Oh, yeah, I was like the last few days
Have a good night. I'm gonna go chill. I was gonna make brownies, but I realize I don't have any eggs
You guys know how empty my fridge is
Have a good night. I hope you guys enjoyed
You smell like a bunch of stinky girls
That doesn't make any sense forget it there's a joke in there I'm tired
You